nebia is a revolutionary shower head
that saves you money by using
45 percent less water but with a stream
of water that's way more powerful
than what you get with other shower
heads to get 15
off go to nebia.com pacman and use the
code pacman
the house of representatives will be
voting later this month
on whether to make washington dc the
51st
state of the united states cbs news
reporting
that house majority leader steny hoyer
wrote in a letter to colleagues two
three days ago that at some point during
april the house will hold a vote
do we make washington dc the 51st
state now of course of course of course
it will almost certainly pass the house
and it will almost certainly go nowhere
in the senate most republicans have
expressed
that they are against making washington
dc
the 51st state this would not be and
will not be the first time that the
house of representatives votes to do
this the house already approved the dc
statehood measure in 2020 by a vote of
232
to 180 but it did not even come to the
floor of the senate now
in 2020 the senate was controlled by
republicans
democrats now control the senate it's 50
50
democrats have a majority because by
controlling the white house kamala
harris becomes
the tie-breaking 51st vote in the senate
but
most legislation needs 60 votes to go
forward
this is not the type of thing making
washington dc a 51st state
that's not something you can move
forward on via budget reconciliation
by every analysis that we've seen so far
so you need to find
10 republicans 10 republicans and
it is extraordinarily unlikely we are
not aware of 10 republicans that want to
move forward
with washington dc as a 51st state
senate majority leader chuck schumer
has committed to bringing it to the
floor for a vote but again
this gets back to the filibuster and we
when we talked what was it
january maybe february when we talked
about the possible paths forward
on the filibuster one of the things that
we explained
was even if there's something you could
pass
with 50 votes you still need 60 to end
debate
this is how this is how the filibuster
works and we talked about some
filibuster reforms making it a talking
filibuster
requiring 40 um requiring 40
of senators in the senate to keep debate
going at all times
we've talked about all these things none
of these changes have been made and so
we listed dc statehood and puerto rican
statehood as
specific possible issues that will go
nowhere
unless some kind of filibuster reform is
done well it's happening now
uh sometime this month the house is
going to vote on making washington dc a
51st state
it is likely to pass it will then go to
the senate and by every indication there
will not even be a vote
on it of course i am in favor of dc
statehood we've talked before
uh about how the population of
washington dc at 700 000 is larger than
the population of the state of wyoming
which has
uh two senators it's larger than the
population of the state of vermont which
has two senators
those in washington dc have no voting
representation
in congress but they do have just as a
sort of factual note eleanor holmes
norton
is a representative for washington d.c
in the house but is a non-voting
delegate so that's the latest i've said
i would love to see this issue of dc
statehood dealt with in a serious manner
by joe biden
the house is going to vote and then it
is likely going to stall in the senate
and at a certain point
democrats and joe biden are going to
have to decide
are we committed to getting these things
done to the degree
that we are going to do something about
the filibuster understanding
that any changes they do make to the
filibuster could be a double-edged sword
that comes back against them when they
are not in control
i support filibuster reform i support
washington dc as a 51st state
i would love to hear from you how should
democrats handle this
i've been covering how right-wing media
has been covering the biden
administration for several months now
and the bottom line is that they do not
know what the hell to do with themselves
the joe biden administration so far has
been completely absent of scandals
they've made some progress in some areas
they've turned around some of the
disasters left behind by the donald
trump administration
for example vaccination has accelerated
dramatically
the economy continues to recover jobs
are recovering
stock market is at a record high joe
biden passed a coronavirus stimulus he's
now pushing infrastructure reform he's
doing guns
he's doing a lot of different things so
right wing media has had to come up
with scandals but they're really boring
and they're sort of what i would call
fake scandals
one is the focus on why joe biden and
kamala harris won't go
to the border and of course you know
they have advisors
uh they don't need to go to the border
to understand what's going on
at the border but that's one fake
scandal that the right has been pushing
they've done the cancel culture stuff
focusing
occasionally and intermittently on dr
seuss or major league baseball or
whatever the case may be
they try gotcha questions at press
briefings with joe biden's press
secretary jen saki or sometimes
with joe biden himself and the gotcha
questions fail day after day after day
in a
humiliating way here is the latest
fake scandal i present to you now an
entire news max segment devoted to how
kamala harris laughs
and when she laughs i'm not kidding here
is a segment
very concerned about kamala's laugh and
drawing a parallel to the wicked witch
of the west i guess from the wizard of
oz take a look
so it got me thinking about kamala's
cackling all right she is probably going
to be president sooner than rather than
later all right
she's supposed to be the leader all
women should look up to
but all i can actually remember her
doing since taking office
is cackling at the most strange moments
too watch
[Laughter]
[Applause]
you know
[Laughter]
not everybody landed punches like you
did though
so you don't mean it
my it's not even funny so
i was racking my brain watching those
clips right there
trying to figure out who in the heck
does this woman remind me of and then i
realized
she's from out west and it hit me
oh boy that's her
that's cackling kamala the wicked witch
of the west
nancy pelosi move over there's a new
witch in town
and her name of course is cackling
kamala
oh how sad is that she is going to be
president by the way i don't think joe
biden's going to be in here for much
longer
we'll see right i don't wish any harm to
him at all but
we shall see guys kamala is laughing
the wrong way and at the wrong time this
is an explosive issue
now if you thought uh first of all
how many segments has newsmax done about
how male
politicians laugh you're asking an
interesting question and as far as i
know the answer is zero
secondly is there some sense in which
this is refreshing because we know that
these aren't real scandals what i mean
by that is
trump failing on coronavirus and the
number of deaths that that caused
trump regularly making the u.s a global
laughingstock
trump launching a misguided trade war
trump crushing farmers with his policy
you know all of these
real issues now the scandal is how
kamala harris laughs and whether major
league baseball should be boycotted
is there some sense in which it's
refreshing that these aren't
real embarrassing scandals at a global
level
i don't know but in all seriousness they
have
no idea what to do with themselves and
it's getting
very embarrassing i would expect more of
this now
at some point there may be a real biden
administration scandal
many administrations have scandals like
for example when barack obama wore a tan
suit that rocked the world so
at some point there may be a real
scandal
and it could very quickly become a sort
of boy who cried wolf type of situation
but kamala laughing guys come on you're
embarrassing yourselves
let me know your thoughts you can find
me on twitter
at d pacman we're going to take some of
your calls i'm going to answer
many of your questions we have a great
program for you today
stay with us back right after this
one of our sponsors today is nebia the
creator of the world's most
innovative shower head it uses only
about
half the water that other shower heads
do saving you money helping the
environment
but it's actually a lot more powerful
than other shower heads on the market it
has twice the coverage of other shower
heads
the water sprays with a ton of pressure
i've been using it in my bathroom at
home i love it
only took a few minutes to set up really
easy and it's been a totally different
experience
than any other shower head i've used i
can get in and out of the shower way
quicker now
because of how powerful it is it only
takes a few seconds to get
completely rinsed off so i was actually
amazed that it's only using about half
as much
water nebia also offers a number of
shower accessories like shelves and
curtains which match
perfectly with the design of the shower
head the shower head starts at just
199 but the first hundred people to go
to nebia.com
pacman and use code pacman will get 15
percent off
all nebia products welcome back we are
going to hear from some
viewers and listeners via discord
momentarily
at davidpakman.com discord
you can of course get a david pakman
show membership
which gives you early access to full
episodes of the show so you can hear
live calls or avoid them depending on
your preference
much earlier than anybody else all right
very very exciting stuff
davidpakman.com discord is the place to
get in touch
with me why don't we go first today
let's try something different
let's go to johanna in chile johanna
you're on the air
hello hello how are you yes please mute
discord because we're hearing the blings
i don't know how to do that actually all
right well what's on your mind today
um uh well uh as you see i'm from chile
i know you are close to me in terms of
argentina yes greetings
well i have a question slash comment uh
is what do you expect from right-wing
media
asking those all those gotcha questions
to
either gents like you or other uh
members of the cabinet of joe biden
sorry you said
asking all of those what questions what
was the word
uh disgusting questions
yeah i think that they're trying to so
here's what's going on johanna there's a
couple things going on
one it's fox news so they want to play
gotcha with democrats that's what they
do
but especially because biden just hasn't
really
had any cartoonish big scandalous
missteps
they're trying to create them they're
trying to create drama where let's face
it
joe biden's administration has been
boring in the sense that he promised to
do vaccines and we're doing three
million vaccines
a day he said that he would do stimulus
and he got it done
he's just working on stuff so they're
trying to create drama where there's
very little drama
but i think uh dan sucky yeah
i don't know well uh is doing a terrific
job
she's doing a good job i think that
she's been
under prepared on some of the
immigration questions where she seems
she has some talking points in front of
her but she doesn't really
deliver them in a coherent way i think
she could be better on immigration but
otherwise i think she's doing a very
good job yeah
thanks all right thank you johanna from
chile great to hear from you
let's go next to um why don't we go
there's just so many people interested
in getting on today
it's hard to know where to go why don't
we go to luke from minnesota next luke
you're on the air uh hello
so i was wondering what you would think
of a potential boycott of the 2020
olympics in uh
uh china you mean the 2022 olympics in
china yes 2022 yes
yeah we we talked about this on the
bonus show earlier this week
there's three types of boycotts that you
can do there can be a diplomatic boycott
where the athletes go
but the country doesn't send
representatives it's sort of like a
diplomatic protest
you can do an athletic boycott where you
don't the country doesn't send any
athletes
and then you can also do what's called
the boycott light which is diplomats and
athletes go
but the diplomats make statements that
are critical
of of the government um i i tend to
think that
i want the athletes there and we've had
so many examples
of conflict between countries during
which
athletes still went and i don't
particularly care about
the olympics but i think it's a good
message to say that
the athletic community is going to
compete
in a way that is not tied to politics
and let the diplomats do what they want
so if they want to do a diplomatic
boycott
okay if they want to do boycott light
but i would definitely send send the
athletes
all right thank you so much that was a
very good answer all right thank you
very much yeah that's
we'll talk more about that i think as we
get
closer to that point in time let's go
next
to um why don't we go to
uh edgar from florida edgar you're on
the air
oh edgar we're gonna have to do
something about uh about your audio
oh yeah okay no problem that's much
better yeah very quick fix
awesome so uh i just wanted to ask
really your opinion
on basically how latin america deals
with their
own racial spectrum i feel like a lot of
the times
in america sorry people
may have an underrated observation
of race relations between you know for
example afro
colombian african colombians and you
know
white colombians for example yes and for
example
in some countries there's a lot of like
there's a big african um colombian maybe
or
or or um ecuadorian population
but maybe not so much in for example
argentina correct me if i'm wrong maybe
you're absolutely right you're
absolutely right
no this is a super important issue edgar
i know that there are some people on the
left
who want to believe the us is like the
most racist country and we just
it's just it's it's disastrous racism
we have problems with race in the united
states that is both
individual racism it's also
structural racism and and the the after
effects
of structural racism that have not yet
been resolved in the inequalities they
deal with
but some of the stuff that goes on there
are many countries that are much more
racist than the united states and i
don't now
i'm not saying argentina is the most
racist country
but because i know argentina because i
was born there
uh attitude there first of all there's
almost no what we
what we in the u.s would call black
folks down there they often refer
to black people who are just like more
what we would call native or or mixed
populations
um they refer to them as black and
often in pejorative terms um
there is a lack of even understanding
like i remember
family members of mine who don't even
realize that the way they're
saying it is sort of strange would say
what is it like the
with the president being black in the
united states and i would be like
i don't know i didn't really think about
it in those terms it's sort of just like
there's a president
um so that's that's argentina and
there's a lot of other examples i could
tell you
there are many countries where the the
issues of racism we could say they're
worse or not as bad
or just different than in the us but the
u.s is not
you know the the worst offender of
racism the u.s has tons of people the
u.s has a
horrible uh history of racism that's
codified in law
and these these are terrible things and
we're still working to fix them and
there's much work to be done
but it's not unique to the united states
absolutely i agree
um wow thanks so much dave and if i
could ask one quick
little extra question you identify as a
basically a
white jewish person or like or as
argentinian how would you
kind of word that yourself because i
have an argentinian friend
yeah who his girlfriend like you know
kind of told him but you're white
like ethnically or like you know
whatever you look like a white guy
and he took offense to that like no i'm
argentinian well you know here's what's
really funny about that
by the u.s census definitions i'm
i'm certainly hispanic there's no
question about that because that's
and you can be white and hispanic or
non-white and hispanic so
by the u.s census i'm absolutely
hispanic
i also am in a sense a white guy
in that people see me as as a white guy
and i learned english young enough that
i don't have an accent in english
except when i'm deliberately
mispronouncing words for the lulls you
understand okay
but then there's another funny thing
which is really my ethnicity
is is ashkenazi jewish like when i do my
dna test
it it doesn't come back you know
european german french it comes back
ashkenazi jewish
white supremacists don't see me as white
now why i care
what they see me as maybe is a different
question for a different day
but the bottom line is i i identify
as a white hispanic that's that's the
way
that i mostly see myself hey same here
buddy
oh man i appreciate the time david all
right edgar from florida
powerful phone call very very exciting
uh okay why don't we go next
to calvin from colorado calvin are you
glad to have the
all-star game coming your way
yes i am good what's on your mind
yeah so i'm just thinking about the
infrastructure bill
yep and uh yeah it's pretty expansive
and uh kirsten gillibrand
today tweeted out that um
you know paid leave and child care
and caregiving are all infrastructure do
you agree with that
i don't know i'd have to think about
that i mean okay so obviously roads and
bridges nobody disagrees with that's
infrastructure
electrical grid broadband
uh green energy many people but
not everybody on the right agrees our
infrastructure
child care and paid leave i mean listen
if we i have no problem getting it done
via infrastructure
no no problem whatsoever is it
infrastructure in the same way as some
of this other stuff i mean i guess the
argument in
favor would be that you are
enabling uh many systems
including uh raising children
because you're able to take time off
from work without losing money you're
enabling many systems to work better
you're you're helping the educational
system you're helping
you know culture society so like you can
make the argument i don't know that it's
it's super obvious to me but if we can
be done through infrastructure i'm glad
to do it that way i'd have to read more
about it i think
right i i try to take a really
holistic view on infrastructure and i
think i think they're
on the right track yeah yeah i mean
let's see what can be done i think
that's also another question
at what point does it become impossible
to get done and i don't know what the
answer is but you're definitely going to
need all democrats on board
i question i question whether family
leave appeals to all 50 democrats in the
senate as part of an infrastructure bill
i don't know that it does
yeah okay calvin from colorado thank you
very much for the call i appreciate it
let's go next to harsh from dallas
you're on the air what's on your mind
hello can you hear me yes i can he did
uh nice to talk to you likewise i
started following your content recently
i'm fairly
new to this country as well i just had a
small question
sure uh so you frequently talk about
re-education and media literacy for a
lot of people in this country
yes i was just wondering uh how would
you
hypothetically make these ideas
mainstream and how do you push these
ideas without sounding like
a nazi propaganda sorry you're saying
that
me talking about media literacy could
sound like nazi propaganda
yeah because re-education when you use
the term re-education
that sounds like what china is doing to
muslims
oh i but i don't call it that i mean i
what i say is
we need to deal with the failings of the
educational system
we need to be teaching media literacy
and philosophy and critical thinking and
epistemology starting
probably in sixth or seventh grade but
no you're right i mean
i i to say that we need re-education
camps or re-education in the u.s the
language of that would not play so well
and i think that should be avoided
okay uh do you think that's ever going
to make it into a policy or something
well you know at the state level most
education in the united states is
governed by state boards of education
and there are states that do teach some
of all or all of these things
so yeah i think i think it's a very
achievable
goal you know does does the texas state
board of education want to be teaching
media literacy and critical thinking to
seventh graders
uh i don't know if judging by the
decisions they make on textbooks it's
not very clear to me but i think that
this is a completely achievable goal
okay harsh from dallas thank you very
very much for the call
we are going to take a very quick break
it's going to be very very quick if
you're holding
don't hang up because i'm going right
back to the discord phone lines
momentarily quick break and back to the
phones
the david pakman show depends on your
support and the easiest way is through
membership which includes the world
famous
bonus show as well as commercial free
audio and video streams of the show
just for members sign up today at
joinpakman.com
coupon code saves you 40 better 21.
okay let's uh hear from a few more folks
via discord you can join the discord at
davidpakman.com discord
let's try overseas again why don't we go
to
scott from scotland what's going on
scott
scott from scotland you are muted you
have to unmute yourself in order for me
to hear you
my apologies my friend do you hear me
well i do
fantastic so a relatively uh
i don't want to say it's a minor point
but maybe not high on the list of
priorities
is legal immigration into the us and
i kind of speak from first-hand
experience here i was i was mid-move
with work to the u.s last march when the
covert situation kicked off and now we
find ourselves in a kind of
a precarious and non-moving position and
so
i know that president trump has
obviously focused on illegal immigration
but
he also did a pretty good job of
decimating legal immigration as well
through the various presidential orders
he put in place
yes and the last of which expired at
midnight on march 31st
which he enacted just before new year's
new year's day
um so in theory the presidential orders
have disappeared for the most part for
the kind of legal immigration bans
but what we're finding and this is
something our work attorneys are
struggling with is that embassies and
u.s consulates around the world
are still refusing to see people or
offer appointments or
even just say when they're going to
start with human services so
i'm just curious from your perspective
where do you see legal immigration going
under this new administration and do you
think it will improve do you think
i don't know maybe clamp down on it and
kind of readjust the system
i don't see a clampdown what you're
describing is not unique to the united
states i have i have
friends that are dealing with this in
different places uh i have a friend
that's in the middle of
uh getting portuguese uh residency
through a so-called golden visa program
and
it's just it's taking forever uh i have
um another friend who's in the middle of
getting israeli citizenship
um all of these systems are just slowed
down and i think that
it's i as the pen as we get out of the
pandemic hopefully over the next six to
12 months
a lot of these bureaucratic nightmares
will become
slightly less nightmarish but the
question of policy is a different one i
think in the immediate things are just
going to go back to the way they were
before the pandemic
policy is going to be dealt with later
yeah that makes a lot of sense i do know
that biden
and his administration were potentially
looking at kind of changes to the h1
lottery system in particular and just
changing how that how that goes but i
guess it'll be interesting to see how
that plays out over the coming months
no doubt about it and so but so now are
you are you no longer
trying to move to the u.s no we're still
in progress
i'm living in a half-packed house and
have been since last march i had an
embassy appointment um last march and
then they
postponed it and again again we put in
an exemption request
for national security exemption because
i work in areas related to national
security and the consulate
um rejected it without even reading it
so wow we're in a bit of a stage a
strange stay at the moment but still
very much
pursuing trying to get things sorted out
all right well i hope things
normalize for you thank you david all
right scott from scotland thank you so
much for the call
we are speaking to folks via discord as
we often do
you can find the discord at
davidpakman.com
slash discord that's the way to
do it let's go to how about
aj in oregon or as the former president
said it oregon aj what's going on
hey david can you hear me just barely aj
we and we've got you cranked up and it's
just
it's just a whisper how about now is
that better
barely barely what what's going on let's
see if we can get your question out
um i was wondering if you had a magic
wand
to enact any policy regarding police
reform
what would you change and why i have a
whole video clip about this where i lay
out about eight to ten different points
and it includes uh training social work
training for police officers
we talk about body cameras we talk about
civilian review boards that actually
work
a national bad actors database uh
there's about eight to ten different
points i i've outlined it pretty
pretty specifically and um there's
probably even more that that could be
added to it but definitely check that
clip out it's on youtube
okay um but uh not anything
specifically out of those like there
isn't anything
uh that you would place above uh all the
others
uh no i didn't prioritize the list i
mean it's a list of about eight to ten
things i did i didn't rank them if
that's the question
okay um i guess more specifically i was
wondering
about the uh body cameras uh
specifically
and uh their impact
because i notice a lot of times with
these uh
issues with police brutality
we're really dependent on body cam to
get a
unbiased sort of recording of the event
yeah my general view is i like the idea
of body cameras
it shouldn't be so easy for them to just
not record
at exactly the key moment and then you
hear about oh the footage is missing the
camera didn't turn on
i know that there are some
small studies that claim complaints for
use of force went up when body cameras
were put in place and a lot of right
wingers will point to that and say
cc we don't need body cameras at the at
the macro level everything i've read is
that use of force complaints
go down when body cameras are are put in
place
so i think there's still details to sort
out but from everything i've read i'm in
favor of body cameras
and uh just the last thing on that so
would you
uh in the course of events where a
body camera is turned off or not
available would you hold the
uh the police department accountable for
that missing footage
if body camera reform was put into place
where they required everyone to
record the course of events
i don't know how you manage that because
there's a big difference between
the officer deliberately turns the
camera off which really it's a question
whether they should even have the
ability to do that
or everything's recorded and then in the
cloud but
somehow the footage disappears
to just genuinely there's a technical
issue you you need a system for
managing all of those different
circumstances i don't know exactly what
that system is right now
all right thank you very much i love the
show
all right there is aj barely audible but
we were able to make it work
always a good thing let's go next
to uh oh let's go to muhammad from qatar
i don't believe we've ever had a call
from qatar before muhammad what's on
your mind
muhammad you have to unmute if you want
me to be able to hear you
muhammad from qatar i would love for you
to be the first qatari caller but
that's probably not going to happen the
way things are looking
all right no muhammad from qatar that's
too bad
that's too bad i was really looking
forward to that let's go to orv
from milwaukee wisconsin hi david
uh can you hear me yes i can oh great
thank you again for taking my call
um i just wanted to talk a little bit
about i guess the
student loans um and um
sort of the crisis that's going on with
that clearly the biden administration
and congressional democrats are
aiming at canceling um some form of
that whether that be 5000 to 50 000 yep
um
it seems that there are some sub-sector
of
of america that is a little bit hesitant
to do this for various reasons whether
that be
paying them down already or not having
in the first place although it
it does seem that the majority of
americans do support that um
and i guess my question would be how do
we address that um would there possibly
be
in the long term um versus just you know
obviously clearly
canceling some portion of that debt is
going to alleviate some of the issue in
the short term but the long term it
seems to me that
predatory loans are maybe more of the
issue rather than the actual
yep um so here's my view
because of if we were rebuilding the
system from scratch we would just build
it in a different way that would prevent
the cycle of it's so easy to get student
loans which makes it easy for colleges
to raise prices
because then you just get the loans and
then you owe more money but wages don't
go up and it becomes unsustainable which
is what we have that's the crisis that
we have we would build the system
differently but
being that we are where we are there
should be
some degree of student loan forgiveness
and i've seen a lot of different
proposals about what that should be
and how it should be targeted as i've
said before it doesn't strike me that
the right way to do it
is to forgive every dollar of student
debt for everybody that doesn't make
sense to me
but i think that some fixed amount plus
more with certain requirements
attached to it is a good way to go
but you're completely right that that
doesn't really solve the problem
because if you just have a policy of we
forgive everyone's loans forever
then schools just keep making school
more expensive but you know the cycle
essentially continues
so i think you can you kind of get back
into that same cycle where
you know you know we're going to wipe
the slate clean but then we haven't
really addressed the root issue of the
problem
exactly you know what i'm thinking in my
head is you know does it make sense to
to you know maybe go with
or establish some sort of a federal loan
program where there is a
um you know little to no interest rate
where
we're providing you know federal dollars
as like a loan so that exists already
that exists already for grad school i
had i had
the federal loans where uh interest
accrual
is suspended for periods of time and so
so that that exists it could be expanded
i think ultimately something needs to be
done to bring the cost of college in
line with with wages
because if you look at how the cost of
college has changed relative to wages in
many fields
it's completely out of whack if you look
at cost of college relative to inflation
relative to
cost of living it's it's completely out
of whack so that's what needs to be
gotten under control
i'm not saying the government just needs
to decide what prices are
um that does that you know i don't think
that that's the solution government sets
prices on private and public
schooling but something needs to get
done be done to rain to get that under
control
and the student loan piece is a problem
that subsidizes colleges continuing to
charge more and more and a one-time
debt forgiveness is not going to deal
with that issue
sure yep all right well hey thanks again
for taking my call i really appreciate
it
my pleasure very important issue orv
appreciate the call
why don't we go next to let's go to
miguel from lima peru one of the places
i was to visit
in 2020 but then miguel the pandemic hit
and i i've i've not been able to do it
yet
that's too bad we would have liked you
to be here i would have liked to have
been there yes i can
right um so my question is about
vaccinations in particular uh being from
a country where
only about one percent of the population
has been able to get vaccinated
um we the the issue being that we're not
able to get vaccines into the country
as efficiently as other countries have
been um i know that some people
who have the economic capability to do
uh to do it are going to places like the
us
in order to get vaccinated yes and in
some in some parts of the us that's
legal i think in texas it is
i know a lot of people personally who
have been there and i wanted to know
your opinion on
the morality behind people who aren't
citizens of the us
going to the u.s specifically to get
vaccinated well listen the morality
it's less a question of the morality of
doing it it's more of
is it allowed and or are they lying i
mean there was a bunch of time
where wealthy argentinians were flying
from buenos aires to miami
and getting vaccinated in miami and
doing shopping and then going
back to argentina and eventually when
florida found out about it they said
they were stopping it that you had to
show proof of residency in florida they
said it
but from what i understand you can
they're not really checking so you can
just
lie so for me the morality is more about
are you doing something dishonest rather
than if if that
if the rules are if if it's 65 plus it
doesn't matter where you live
you could live in any state in any
country as long as you're 65 plus
you're not really doing anything wrong
if you can afford to go to that state
and to get the vaccine it's really more
of an administrative question
i think the spirit of the doses that
the biden administration has obtained
are for americans
and it's that's economic nationalism
countries are mostly looking out for
themselves right now
and i understand why and it's creating a
huge imbalance where there are poor
countries that that have very few
vaccines and may have none for a long
period of time
i don't know exactly how to solve that
but the morality of an individual
if the state is allowing it the
individual is not really doing anything
wrong
right that makes sense uh it's kind of
the way i'm seeing it
you know if i have the opportunity to go
and get vaccinated myself or in
particular my parents were
older yeah um i i would want them to do
that
also i mean it's definitely an issue of
um
when we will be able to get vaccinated
here in peru and
honestly um as someone who lives here
it's it's mostly a question of when the
u.s
and europe will have return hurt
immunity everyone who wants to get
vaccinated has gotten vaccinated
understandably those could be two
different things too you may have a
situation in the u.s where everyone who
wants it has gotten it and we are not at
herd immunity that could happen
that's a good point uh at which point i
would hope that
the u.s or europe would just sell the
vaccines to countries like peru
and then i could get vaccinated yeah i
think the u.s is planning to give them
not just sell them i think that the u.s
plans to give them to other countries
hello yeah there you go uh so yes uh
all right well we're gonna follow it and
hopefully hopefully more vaccines and
more places soon you know
thank you david all right thank you a
beautiful phone call from
lima peru why don't we go
next we have a little bit of time left
and we could we could talk to some more
people
let's go to john from orange county
california what's going on john
hey david can you hear me yes i can
okay um well basically
i just wanted to get your thoughts about
the future of georgia um
in terms of like uh national elections
in the future
okay i've i've heard from like sam
cedar and and and his crew that
these these ideas about if it's going to
become
a battleground state or not and that's
something that i thought
would be an interesting topic to hear
you talk about yeah we
we've addressed this a number of times
uh demographically
there seems to be evidence that points
to georgia being a more reliable
purple state certainly what happened in
2020
joe biden won two republican incumbent
senators
were unseated by two democratic
challengers
there's every indication that this could
be a
permanent swing state rather than the
mostly reliable red state i think 2022
will give us a little bit of a signal
and then 2024 maybe more of one
right right um and
and sort of i guess a follow-up to that
um and this thing is an interesting
question is why do you think
that change happened and i know that
part of that reason is probably due to
the trump administration but just
um demographics and voter registration
two things have gone on in georgia
people moving to georgia that are more
left-leaning
and people like stacy abrams and others
getting
left-leaning people who may not be
engaged with the political system
registered and out to vote right
right i see okay
well thank you just uh john i have to
ask were you slapping something while
you were talking to me
no you weren't interested no i was not
interesting
all right john thank you very much for
the call
yeah all right very good uh john from
orange county california all right
everybody that's
all the time i have for calls today i'm
sorry
i am sorry i wasn't able to get to
everybody
but i will take calls again
the david pakman show depends on the
support of our viewers and listeners and
one way to keep us going
is through patreon where you can pledge
as little
as one dollar per month or as much as
you want
at patreon.com slash david pakman show
great perks and benefits as well read
about him alright let's get into
audience questions for the week david
shouldn't joe biden be bragging about
the stock market the way trump did
i don't mean because joe biden is
actually responsible for the stock
market
but because trump seemed to do well when
he bragged about it
i i like the way that this question is
asked because
it's not being asked as a question of
whether joe biden deserves credit i mean
as we've talked about
before to some degree the
sort of economic circumstances uh
over which a president has some
influence
impact the stock market but the stock
market performance
alone is often used kind of as a
political football and donald trump
certainly regularly would talk about how
great the stock market is doing when it
was up
not when it was down and many of his
followers fell for it it's really a
question of whether politically it would
be advantageous for joe biden to do it
i think that it's not clear that it
would because
joe biden's base is so different than
donald trump's base donald trump's base
was
disproportionately made up of people who
were never involved in politics before
or who were and they fell for republican
nonsense
so they were like the perfect marks for
just hearing from trump
about the stock market and the joe biden
base
is different and it doesn't strike me
as something that would be so obviously
beneficial for joe biden to brag about
the stock
market in the same way that donald trump
did now that being said
just because you don't have the sort of
sycophantic
cult of personality cheerleaders on the
left that you had
on the right around donald trump doesn't
mean joe biden shouldn't
talk about the stock market in the
context
of talking about how we're doing so
certainly joe biden should be saying
we're vaccinating more than three
million a day
cova deaths are down 77 percent cases
are down roughly the same percentage
uh unemployment is down we are seeing
job creation
stock market is at record highs on and
up right so it's a package
overall but if the question is should
joe biden
start tweeting about the stock market
from a golf course the way you know the
caricature of what donald trump was
doing
i don't think it's uh it's what joe
biden should be doing
one other aspect to why it's important
for biden
to talk about the stock market numbers
is that you do want to try at least
to get the media to
put out messages that are advantageous
to you
any president would try to do this and
rather than just leaving it to corporate
media to figure out oh the stock market
is doing well and joe biden's president
and we were told that it was going to be
a disaster by trump if joe biden were
president
why not again this this is sort of like
communications in pr
feed the story to the media in in some
sense
one one other aspect of this
when donald trump insisted during the
campaign
that if joe biden wins your 401ks will
be worth nothing
the economy will collapse unemployment
will explode
coveted death will explode suicides will
explode
you won't have windows and buildings you
won't have indoor heating you won't have
indoor cooling you'll have to flush your
toilet 10 to 15 times you'll have to run
your dishwasher two or three times to
get your dishes clean
we knew all that stuff was crazy but in
particular now
joe biden talking about what the stock
market is doing
might be a good way to get media outlets
to put more republicans on the spot and
say
you agreed with trump during the
campaign that if joe biden were
president this would happen to the
market
the markets at record highs what say you
they would almost
certainly retreat to something like well
joe biden has inflated the stock market
by quote
printing money through stimulus and he
wants to do infrastructure
but they'll be on the ropes and they
will have a defense it'll be a really
stupid defense so the the position joe
biden should take is
take credit for
turning things around and talk about the
stock market
as one of many indicators as to how
things are continuing to improve
david the more i see the left get
involved in these cultural issues
like cancel culture and wokeness the
more i think the left should just not
even bother to fight those
issues what do you think this is a very
interesting question
um we see that right now there's
a really big divide between the
democratic and republican party
in the sense that the democratic party
is
almost exclusively about legislation and
issues
and the republican party is not and
earlier this week i
argued with republican strategist amanda
mackey about it
who i still don't even know exactly what
point she was trying to make but
needless to say
her argument is well now republicans
can't do policy because they don't
control anything well but they didn't do
any policy during the trump era either
um
as a result the right is just fighting
cultural issues they're talking about
uh cancel culture they're talking about
um control you know transports
control of uh the narrative by the left
wokeness and all of this different stuff
i don't believe that the left should
give
up those issues but i do think that it
would be best
for the the left to realize that just
because an issue
is getting a lot of traction on twitter
and fox news
doesn't mean it's actually an issue that
much of the democratic electorate cares
about and you need
look only at the 2020 democratic primary
to understand that
and i know this is painful for many in
my audience to hear
i wish it were different but there were
a lot of people
millions of people on the left who spent
a lot of time on twitter and reddit
and saw the enthusiasm for bernie
sanders at rallies
and wrongly believed that the bernie
wing of the democratic electorate
was is bigger than it actually is it
doesn't mean it's insignificant
it doesn't mean it doesn't matter it
doesn't mean that that it's not
a wing with good ideas it is but
the 2020 democratic primary
reminded us when it wasn't even close i
mean joe biden really won very easily by
millions of votes
even before it was you know everybody
bailed and all that all that stuff
um what you see on reddit and twitter
and on newsmax or fox news
it's not what the bulk of the country
actually cares about
and similarly for me it's not about the
left
conceding or giving up on the cultural
issues
it's understanding that most americans
are not focused in on trans sports
wokeness dr seuss or cancel culture
they're just not
uh first of all tons of americans don't
even pay attention
to news in the way that you and i do and
of those that do
we know the issues that are most
important it's in no particular order
the economy jobs wages healthcare
coronavirus pandemic recovery those
those are the issues
those are the primary issues so
once you understand that and then you
realize that very little of these
culture wars
involve actual policymakers in policy
positions
this is an important distinction yes
congressman jim jordan will go on laura
ingram's show and
talk about the cancel culture laura you
know he does that
matt gates when he's trying to distract
from you know investigations into child
sex trafficking
he will talk about cancel culture trump
talked i get it
you see people like you know marjorie
taylor greene or whatever
try to bring some of this stuff to the
house floor jim jordan
says you need an investigation into dr
seuss for the most part
very little of this culture war stuff is
even touching
real policy making legislative uh
time at the state level uh and at the
national level it's
amplified by conservatives a few of them
it's amplified by the internet it's
amplified by some right-wing media
so the way i would say it is democrats
don't need to
just concede a loss on cultural issues
democrats don't need to not bother
fighting on cultural issues democrats
just need to
recognize that the culture war
is a distraction that republicans have
chosen to take on
because they have no policy ideas other
than prevent democrats from doing
anything
and they have nothing to actually bring
to the table at this point in time
one last thought on this eventually
democrats tend to be vindicated on most
of these cultural issues i mean
look at abortion okay it took
what 40 50 years abortion
being legal in most cases is more
popular now
than at any point since roe v wade it
took a while but the culture
shifted and caught up with where quote
the left has been
gay marriage most people in the u.s
including more than 50 percent of
republicans now believe
gay marriage should just be legal it's
been legal since 2015.
democrats the left have been fighting
for that for much longer
eventually the culture came around
marijuana approval
death penalty not being you get it right
so another reason not to engage
in the way that the right wants to
is that eventually the country tends to
come around now you don't want to ignore
serious issues like death penalty
marijuana etc
altogether because if you do then
nobody's advocating for your side but
the cancel culture thing is different
and i do think that democrats should
just understand that this is not a big
issue to most americans
period david does kamala harris have a
better shot at being president
if biden does run for re-election in 24
or if he does not there's no way
to answer this question without knowing
what 2024 will look like the
the the j i get the gist of the question
it's unclear if joe biden is running for
reelection he recently said he plans to
it's my intention that's not exactly i
am running
he might run for reelection in 2024 and
if he wins maybe kamala would run in
2028
he might not run in 2024 which would be
an opportunity for kamala harris to run
i think that all we can say now is that
being vice president is a good stepping
stone to the presidency
there's there's arguably no better
stepping stone now i know tons of you
are going to say david
look at all the times vice presidents
have run and they
lost look at al gore look at um
i don't even know you know there's all
these instances of vice presidents who
ran
and uh oh look at joe biden in uh
2016. he didn't even win the primary
okay 15 vice presidents have
eventually become president now they
didn't all win elections right there are
other circumstances as well so that's
like
a very high percentage of compared to
any other job
vice president being a good stepping
stone to president
um you know at any given time there are
50 governors
there's a hundred senators there's one
vice president
and uh it is historically
a good statistical stepping stone
statistical stepping stone doesn't mean
that you win every time
so i have no idea whether you know the
question of whether it's better for
kamala
to to run in 2024 or 2028 depends on
what's going on if biden has a hugely
successful
first term and says i'm not going to run
it's probably good for kamala harris
if biden has a very bad first term
and doesn't run it's probably not a
great opportunity for kamal harris
similarly to what might be happening in
2028 it's really
less about a vice president running
than it is about what are the
circumstances in the country
under that vice president's uh tenure
and what is the sort of
mindset of the country you know joe
biden maybe would have done better in
2016
had there not been eight years of
virulently racist and xenophobic
activation against barack obama which
biden obviously was associated with as
the vice president it's very hard to go
back and run any other scenario
so i tend to just look at history it
even though many vps have tried to
become president and lost
there is still no more statistically
reliable
job for becoming president of the united
states
than being vice president of the united
states and we will just have to wait and
see what happens
we have a tremendous bonus show for you
today get instant access by becoming a
member
at joinpakman.com we are also here next
week
no more vacation for a little while oh
we will see you on monday if you are not
a member but you should be
you really should be
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors
nebia is a revolutionary shower head
that saves you money by using 45 percent
less water but with a stream of water
that's way more powerful
than what you get with other shower
heads to get 15
off go to nebia.com pacman and use the
code
pacman